welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today we are discussing
journaling for mental and physical
health I want to emphasize that today's
discussion is not a general discussion
about the value of journaling rather it
is a discussion about a particular form
of journaling that the scientific
peerreview data says is especially
powerful for improving our mental and
physical health in fact what I will
describe today is a journaling method
that is supported by over 200
peer-reviewed studies in quality
journals and I frankly was not aware of
this journaling practice prior to
researching this episode but in
researching this episode have come to
discover that this practice should
easily be placed among some of the other
critical so-called foundational pillar
practices
in terms of its impact on improving
mental and physical health including
things like lowering anxiety improving
sleep improving immunity to things like
colds flu Etc as well as reducing the
symptoms of autoimmune disorders such as
arthritis lupus and also providing some
relief for fibromyalgia which is a
condition of excessive pain the
particular journaling method and
protocol that I will describe has also
been shown to improve various metric Tri
of everyday living including improved
memory decision- making and on and on
and on so much so that again I was very
surprised that I had not heard of this
particular journaling method one would
think that if such a powerful method
existed that everyone would know about
it but it turns out that this particular
journaling method has been somewhat
cloistered within the fields of
psychology and Psychiatry it's not that
nobody was aware of it in fact I learned
about it for the first time from our
associate chair of Psychiatry at
Stanford for University School of
Medicine my colleague and collaborator
Dr David Spiegel who as some of you may
know has been featured as a guest on
this podcast previously and upon hearing
about it I decided to explore the
primary research that is the studies
that demonstrate the power of this
particular journaling method and was
absolutely Blown Away by the positive
impact this particular journaling method
can have what's wonderful about it
you'll soon discover is that it takes a
relatively small amount of time in fact
it's something that you could do during
the the course of one week or even
across one month and then never do again
and the data say that it would still
have lasting positive benefits both for
body and mind so while it's rare to
feature one particular protocol as an
entire huberman Lab podcast that is
indeed what I will do today it is
important that we go into some depth
about the specific protocol because
there are some important details that
everyone should know if they want to
apply it and make it as effective as it
can be and in addition to that we'll
talk about some of the underlying
science that that's been published
explaining why and how this protocol is
so effective for mental and physical
health before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is element
element is an electrolyte drink that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't that means plenty electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium and no
sugar the electrolytes are absolutely
essential for the functioning of every
cell in your body and your neurons your
nerve cells rely on sodium magnesium and
potassium in order to communicate with
one another electrically and chemically
element contains the optimal ratio of
electrolytes for the functioning of
neurons and the other cells of your body
every morning I drink a packet of
element dissolved in about 32 ounces of
water I do that just for General
hydration and to make sure that I have
adequate electrolytes for any activities
that day I'll often also have an element
packet or even two packets in 32 to 60
ounces of water if I'm exercising very
hard and certainly if I'm sweating a lot
in order to make sure that I replace
those electrolytes if you'd like to try
element you can go to drink lnt.com
huberman to get a free sample pack with
your purchase again that's drink lnt.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by 8 sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity I've spoken many
times before in this podcast about the
fact that getting a great night's sleep
really is the foundation of mental
health physical health and performance
one of the key things to getting a great
night's sleep is to make sure that the
temperature of your sleeping environment
is correct and that's because in order
to fall and stay deeply asleep your body
temperature actually has to drop by
about 1 to 3° and in order to wake up
feeling refreshed and energized your
body temperature actually has to
increase by about 1 to 3° with eight
sleep you can program the temperature of
your sleeping environment in the
beginning middle and end of your night
it has a number of other features like
tracking the amount of rapid eye
movement and slow wave sleep that you
get things that are essential to really
dialing in the perfect night's sleep for
you I've been sleeping on an eight Sleep
mattress cover for well over two years
now and it has greatly improved my sleep
I fall asleep far more quickly I wake up
far less often in the middle of the
night and I wake up feeling far more
refreshed than I ever did prior to using
an eights Sleep mattress cover if you'd
like to try eight sleep go to 8sleep.com
huberman now through November 30th as a
special holiday discount eight sleep is
offering $500 off their bundles with a
pod cover eight sleep currently ships in
the USA Canada the UK select countries
in the EU and Australia again that's
8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by waking up waking up is a
meditation app that includes hundreds of
meditation programs mindfulness
trainings yoga NRA sessions and nsdr
nonsleep deep rest protocols I started
using the waking up app a few years ago
because even though I've been doing
regular meditation since my teens and I
started doing Yoga Nidra about a decade
ago my dad mentioned to me that he had
found an app turned out to be the waking
up app which could teach you meditations
of different durations and that had a
lot of different types of meditations to
place the brain and body into different
states and that he liked it very much so
I gave the waking up app a try and I too
found it to be extremely useful because
sometimes I only have a few minutes to
meditate other times I have longer to
meditate and indeed I love the fact that
can explore different types of
meditation to bring about different
levels of understanding about
Consciousness but also to place my brain
and body into lots of different kinds of
States depending on which meditation I
do I also love that the waking up app
has lots of different types of Yoga
Nidra sessions for those of you who
don't know Yoga Nidra is a process of
lying very still but keeping an active
mind it's very different than most
meditations and there's excellent
scientific data to show that yoganidra
and something similar to it called
non-sleep deep rest or nsdr can greatly
restore levels of cognitive and physical
energy even with just a short 10-minute
session if you'd like to try the waking
up app you can go to waking up.com
huberman and access a free 30-day trial
again that's waking up.com huberman to
access a free 30-day trial okay let's
talk about this particularly
transformative form of journaling that
initially was researched by Dr James
pennebaker James pennebaker was a
professor of psychology at Southern
Methodist University when he first
started researching this form of
journaling and its positive impacts on
the body and mind but he has since moved
to the University of Texas Austin where
he still runs a laboratory and has
continued his studies on the role of
journaling and other forms of language
both spoken and written in terms of
their impact on one's mental and
physical health so the origins of the
research into this particular form of
journaling started in the mid 80s and it
was really in 1986 that the first
published manuscript about this form of
journaling was published now I want to
be clear that prior to James penay Baker
studying this form of journaling clearly
others had used the form of journaling
that I'm about to describe however it
was pen aaker that really started
attaching measurements of the specific
types of changes that occurred in people
when they did this journaling in a
particular way and indeed came up with
the precise protocol that we'll talk
about today so pennebaker and colleagues
and James pennebaker in particular
really deserves credit for the discovery
of this method as you'll soon learn
pennebaker was absolutely meticulous in
figuring out exactly how long the method
should be carried out what exact forms
of change occurred in the body and mind
he was careful to explore the method in
the context of students as well as in
the general population in veterans in
elderly in kids and on and on so it's
really that incredible attention to
detail and that scientific rigor that
makes the protocol so incredibly
powerful so that first scientific study
of this particular form of journaling as
I mentioned was published in 1986 and I
provided a link to that study in the
show note captions but what that study
essentially consisted of was inviting
undergraduate students into the
university laboratory one at a time and
they were to spend 15 to 30 minutes
writing about the most difficult even
traumatic or possibly non-traumatic but
still very difficult experience that
they can recall from their entire life
the instruction included that they
should write for the entire time that is
because they were writing by hand in
that particular particular experiment
that they were to not stop moving their
hand for the entire duration of the 15
to 30 minutes and in addition to that
that no one besides them the person
writing would see what was written at
the beginning middle or even after the
experiment in fact the students were
invited to tear up the paper at the end
of the writing exercise if they so chose
okay so the first key instruction is
that they take a moment to think about
what is the most difficult perhaps even
traumatic experience of their entire
life the second instruction was that
they were supposed to write for 15 to 30
minutes and the third instruction was
that they were supposed to write for the
entire time that it no point would they
take a pause Unless somehow emotionally
or physically they were unable to keep
moving their hand on the paper in fact
they were told to not pay attention to
Accurate grammar to not pay attention to
reread ability they were told in fact
that their writing could be replete with
spelling errors or grammatical errors
that didn't matter what was most
important is that they tap into a
particularly negatively charge memory of
their prior life experience now of
course because this was an experiment
carried out in a university laboratory
there was a quiet place where the
students could write undisturbed but
since we're taking this particular
protocol and we're exporting it to the
real world through this podcast so it's
important that if you decide to
implement this protocol in your own life
that you carry out the writing in a
place where you will not be disturbed
for that entire 15 to 30 minute duration
it's also important that you know that
even though that first 1986 study was
done having students write out these
memories by hand with a pen and paper or
a pencil and paper there have been many
subsequent studies that have explored
whether or not the pen and paper was
particularly important it turns out it's
not the exact same magnitude of positive
effects are observed regardless of
whether or not people write out their
passage of words by hand or type it out
on a word processor or any other form of
writing now just to make sure that
everyone gets the exact same protocol
that was provided in that first initial
study from pennebaker and colleagues and
that has been used really over and over
and over again for more than 200
peer-reviewed studies that demonstrate
the power of this protocol I'm going to
read to you some of the specific
instructions from that first study so
the subjects were instructed to quote
write about something that you are
thinking about or worrying about way too
much or if you're not thinking about or
worrying about something way too much
perhaps you've deliberately tried to not
think about this series of events or
event something that you've been
dreaming about at night perhaps in
disturbing dreams or something that you
feel is affecting your life in an
unhealthy way either internally or
externally so it could be in your
emotional state your inability to calm
down when you want to be calm maybe
you're ruminating maybe even compulsive
thought maybe it's leading to addictive
or compulsive or habitual behaviors or
perhaps you can identify by a specific
trauma or set of traumas that you know
are really plaguing your body and mind
The Specific Instructions that were
given to the subjects in those
experiments are The Specific
Instructions that I'm going to give to
you now should you decide to implement
this journaling protocol and those
instructions are as follows I want you
to write down your deepest emotions and
thoughts as they relate to the most
upsetting experience in your life really
let go and explore your feelings and
thoughts about it as you write you might
tie this experience to your childhood
your relationship with your parents or
siblings people you have loved or love
now or even your career or
schooling how has this experience
related to who you have now become who
you have been in the past and who you
would like to become the instructions
then continue to say many people have
not had a truly traumatic experience in
their lives but everyone has had major
conflicts or stressors and you can write
about the most dramatic or stressful
experience you've ever had okay so those
are some of the key instructions that
subjects in these experiments were given
before they do the exercise and of
course they were given a few minutes to
think about what they wanted to write
but once they selected what they wanted
to write they started writing there was
a timer going in the background for 15
to 30 minutes and the Reason by the way
I keep saying 15 to 30 minutes is that
some experiments employed a 30-minute
period other experiments employed a
20-minute period others employed a
15minute period turns out there were no
major differences between the 15minute
and the 30 minute writing blocks in
terms of the positive impact that they
had on mental and physical health but
for some people and their particular
experience that they're writing about 15
minutes is simply going to be too brief
a time in order to capture the entire
experience and as many thoughts and
feelings about that experience as one
would perhaps put down onto paper or
type out if they had a full 30 minutes
so you can allow yourself 15 to 30
minutes and feel welcome to stop before
the 30 minute period is over over or
perhaps you're going to restrict
yourself to 15 minutes and you're going
to force yourself to get out as much as
possible in that time it really doesn't
matter or so say the data okay so before
I continue to detail the specifics of
this writing protocol you've probably
already noticed that what I'm describing
is a very different form of journaling
than say morning notes which is a form
of journaling that writers often use in
order to quote unquote clear out the
Clutter this is a process of sitting
down and writing down in stream of
consciousness whatever's on your mind
for the first 5 to 15 maybe even 30
minutes every morning as a way to sort
of clear out your mental processes and
get ready for the day perhaps a day of
other forms of writing or other
activities entirely what I'm describing
is also distinctly different from
so-called gratitude journaling in fact
it's quite the opposite it's not writing
about things that you're grateful for
necessarily it's writing about things
that are extremely unfortunate that
happened to you and that you have very
charged negative emotions about in
addition the form of journaling that
we're talking about today is distinctly
different from the form of journaling
that I and many others have undertaken
perhaps not on a daily basis but perhaps
on a daily basis where you essentially
are writing out the contents of your
daily life a so-called diary and I
mention that because I think many people
do journal and some do so on a
consistent basis I would put myself into
that category although the last few
years I have not been journaling too
much I have literally Stacks and stacks
of Journal journals dating back to uh
the early 90s I brought a few of them
along today and no I'm not going to read
them to any of you in fact um when I was
looking at these last night uh and by
the way these are from the late so this
is Summer of 1997 so I would have been
uh late in my uh undergraduate career
this is um fall of 96
1992 uh always done on the same
composition notebook at that time and
always done by hand um I'm surprised
that my handwriting was as legible as it
was it's gotten worse over the years I
don't know what neural process that
reflects but in any event in Reading
over these journal entries um it was
clear to me that just as I had recalled
that each and every one of them was
essentially an update about what was
happening lately what I was hoping for
some challenges you know basically a
diary of sorts and um these are kept in
the second drawer of the second no I'm
just kidding uh the idea for me is also
that no one will ever read these besides
me it was uh quite an interesting
exercise to to go back and and read
those and uh yeah there were a few
cringe moments but there were also a few
moments where I found myself smiling
because um in certain ways uh so little
has changed between the person I was
then and the person I am now and
fortunately uh in so many ways certain
things have changed between the person I
was then and the person I am now now I
mention all of that simply because I
think the form of journaling that I've
been doing for some years the sort of
autobiographical approach to daily
entries or pseudo daily ENT R is far and
a way different than the type of
journaling that we're talking about for
sake of improving mental and physical
health during today's episode which is
not to say that gratitude journaling or
autobiographical daily entries AK diary
type journaling is not useful in fact
there are data to support that gratitude
journaling in particular can be very
beneficial for both body and mind
everything from improving General states
of Happiness to reducing anxiety
improving relationships and and on and
on but to get back to the protocol that
we're talking about today you probably
noticed that it is not a protocol that's
likely to feel very good at least not at
first and indeed that's what the
research shows and this is something
that you really need to be aware of that
when subjects are given this research
assignment during the assignment they
are often quite distraught often times
they cry often times they find
themselves holding their breath and
anxiety often times they'll finish that
15 to 30 minute writing block and
they'll feel as if they had run a mental
marathon and therefore the subjects were
given a period of 5 to 15 minutes post-
writing to settle down and transition
back into their day so I highly
recommend that you incorporate that into
your protocol as well so if you're going
to allow yourself say 20 minutes to
write you want to give yourself probably
10 minutes of quiet time to you know
bring your composure back and reset
yourself so that you can re-enter daily
living because the writing that you're
going to do for this particular protocol
is designed to tap into very negative if
not the most negative experiences of
your life and so that's something to be
taken seriously and it's an entirely
unreasonable expectation that you could
write about something as difficult as
the most difficult experience in your
life and then simply pivot and go back
into everyday life right away so you'll
want to designate a time of day or night
perhaps when you can do this writing and
still allow yourself some time to you
know settle down your autonomic system
you know return your breathing to normal
perhaps you know wash your face with
some cool water remind yourself that the
rest of the day continues that you're
doing great in fact you made it through
this first installment of the journaling
exercise so you're probably starting to
get the impression that this form of
journaling that Penna Baker and
colleagues really researched and
pioneered the evolution of is quite
different than other forms of journaling
and in fact it's very different I've
already told you that the idea is to sit
down and write for 15 to 30 minutes
right continuously write about something
that really to you is one of the most if
not the most difficult experiences of
your life in addition to that for this
form of journaling to be most effective
that is to bring about the greatest
positive shifts in mental and physical
health you're actually going to write
about that exact same thing four times
now the way that that was initially
researched by penne Baker and others was
to have the same person of course write
about the same experience four times on
four consecutive days for 15 to 30
minutes each so students or people from
the general population or veterans were
literally coming into the laboratory and
sitting down and writing about the most
difficult experience of their life that
they could recall for 15 to 30 minutes
on one day and then again on the next
day and then the next day and the next
day so much of the data on this
particular journaling method reflects
that four consecutive days of 15 to 30
minute writing bouts of the most
difficult experience that you can
recall however there have been
variations on this protocol such that
people selected one day per week and it
doesn't even have to be the same day
like every Monday it could be Monday of
one week and then Wednesday of the next
week and so on such that you write only
one day per week about the most
difficult experience you can recall and
then you write about that same difficult
experience one week later and then again
one week later and then again one week
later across the course of a month or
any 4-we period for that matter now I
don't know about you but when I hear
that that I'm going to need to write
about the most difficult experience of
my entire life that I can recall for
even 15 minutes let alone 30 minutes let
alone two times and here we're talking
about four times perhaps even on four
consecutive days that actually speaks to
some intensity some demand in fact I
find myself kind of leaning away from
that experience a little bit but as
we'll talk about later that's exactly
the point of this type of exercise which
is that we are harboring these stories
these experiences and in some cases
partial Recollections and in other case
detailed Recollections of the difficult
thing that happened to us perhaps even
the most difficult thing that happened
to us and those narratives exist in our
nervous system these are not necessarily
traumas as we talked about before
although they can be traumas now we hear
a lot about trauma and these days people
call all sorts of things trauma and
traumatizing and say that they've been
traumatized by this or traumatized by
that there's actually a specific
definition of trauma that was provided
by Dr Paul kti who is some of you know
is a medical doctor and psychiatrist
he's been a guest on this podcast first
to talk about trauma he wrote a
excellent book about trauma I provide a
link to that book in the show note
captions by the way and he and I did
four episodes of The hubman Lab podcast
a So-Cal guest series specifically aimed
at mental health what it is how to build
mental health specific protocols and Dr
Paul kti is really truly a world expert
in trauma and he defines trauma as any
experience or experiences plural that
modify our brain and neural circuitry so
it could be brain or body or both such
that we do not function as well
emotionally
behaviorally or cognitively going
forward from that experience okay so not
everything constitutes a trauma but many
things do so applying that definition I
think it's fair to say that many if not
most people have some form of trauma
stored in their nervous system and other
people perhaps don't have such traumas
but everyone has had stressors in fact I
think it's fair to say that everyone has
had major stressors in their life
provided that they've lived it all
that's just part of life unfortunately
or maybe fortunately maybe it makes us
who we are in positive ways if we are
able to transmute those negative
experiences and stressors or traumas
into particular forms of learning that
allow us to do better and indeed that's
possible and that was discussed with
Paul kti in that four episode series on
Mental Health but the particular form of
journaling that we're talking about
today was really designed to have people
focus on those difficult experiences and
then for four episodes total yes total
there's no ongoing every week or you
know it's not like having to seek out
sunlight every morning and getting
sunlight in your eyes or trying to get
the best possible night sleep at night
like I'm always encouraging people to do
this is really a short-term protocol but
it's one that is indeed very intense
okay so along those lines that
deliberately journaling about a
particularly distressing experience or
set of experiences is likely to bring
some degree of you know sadness anxiety
frustration anger perhaps other emotions
as well it's important that you know
some some of the data that have been
collected about this journaling protocol
one of the more important features of
this protocol is that when people do it
they tend to bin out into two different
groups and these two groups have been
described as low expressors and high
expressors now low expressors and high
expressors have nothing to do with
introversion and extroversion that's
actually been looked at and they have no
relationship okay so some people who are
very talkative and very
extroverted they could be a low
expressor somebody who's very
introverted tends to only you know share
when they really have something to say
and maybe doesn't have a lot of interest
in social interactions or as some of you
who heard the episode on relationships
know an actual introvert is somebody who
really enjoys social interactions but
they are very sated they are very
satisfied by less social interaction
than our extroverts okay if you want to
learn more about that check out the
episode I did on relationships but in
any event when people sit down to do
this exercise and and when they consent
to having their writing analyzed and
when they undergo a number of other
different tests turns out there are two
different groups that segment out the
first are these low expressors the low
expressors tend to use less descriptive
language in their writing they tend to
get less emotional during the first bout
of writing that first day of 15 to 30
minute writing whereas the high
expressors tend to be people that use a
lot of negative language to describe
their negative emotions about the
negative experience so that means more
negative descriptor words were used at
higher frequency these people when they
have their physiology measured also tend
to have higher amounts of distress and
upset in the first bout of writing that
first 15 to 30 minute episode so we've
got two different groups the low
expressors and the high expressors the
low expressors on day one are sharing a
bit less they're expressing Less on
paper of their particular emotions that
they can recall from that traumatic or
very distressing event and overall based
on physiological measures as well so
cortisol increases as well as Skin
conductance changes in heart rate and
blood pressure the lower expressors are
effectively relatively more calm less
distressed as they write about this very
stressful event in their lives relative
to the high expressors who have higher
blood pressure higher heart rate they
tend to be the ones that cry more or
hold their breath more or SOB more have
higher levels of ctis all during that
first round of writing now for the
protocol to be effective it doesn't
matter if you're in the low expressor or
high expressor group here's what's
interesting I just mentioned that on day
one the low expressors are less
distressed physiologically and
psychologically as they write about this
for them very distressful event whereas
the high expressors are much more
distressed significantly more so in fact
when these are measured in laboratory
studies on both mental and physical
dimensions of of stress now that's on
day one but then what's observed is an
opposite pattern of progression such
that the low
expressors become more and more
distressed as the writing exercise
continues from day two 3 and four
whereas the high expressors these people
that use a lot of language to
communicate their distress and are
experiencing a lot of physiological and
emotional distress as they're writing on
day one their amount of distress
from day 1 to two to 3 to four actually
goes down more dramatically so you can
expect that you fall into one or the
other group this was truly a binary
distribution where people bend out into
one or the other based on a number of
different measurements but here's the
good news turns out it doesn't matter
whether or not you're a low expressor or
a high expressor you want to use the
form of writing that's most natural for
you and that for you communicates what
that negative experience was like and
how it has affected you and perhaps how
it's affected others as well the
important thing to know is that both
groups both the low expressors and the
high expressors benefit from this
journaling protocol such that three
weeks later and even three months later
and even years later both groups are
experiencing far less distress and
Baseline levels of stress than they did
prior to embarking on the journaling
protocol at the very beginning now the
reason I mention these two groups the
low expressors and the high expressors
is that it's a non-trivial detail of
this writing protocol because some
people are very familiar with
communicating their emotions both in
writing and perhaps in speech as well
and this actually has been looked at uh
there's a wonderful study also by penne
Baker and colleagues and I should
mention that even though he studied
these journaling protocol for a good
number of years his laboratory has
evolved now to studying all sorts of
things related to how the particular
language usage patterns that people use
in everyday speech as well as in their
writing how that reflects their
underlying psychological tone and
emotions but also and I find this so
interesting how the particular words
that we use in writing and speech
actually shape in a causal way our
emotional state so I'll talk a little
bit about that later but the important
thing to focus on now is the results of
this study entitled natural emotion
vocabularies as Windows on stress and
well-being and this again is a study
that was done by pen Baker and
colleagues I've linked to it in the show
note captions and it essentially
examines people's natural language usage
patterns now what do I mean by natural
and why is that important well there
have been many many studies of people's
vocabulary and assessing whether or not
people have more knowledge of negative
words to describe negative emotions or
positive emotions these studies are
varying in their form but generally
consist of having people Circle words
they recognize or maybe writing out the
definitions to and it turns out that
people that have more extensive
knowledge of words that describe
negative emotions themselves tend to
have a lower affect or negative
emotional state as compared to people
who have more extensive knowledge of
vocabulary words that pertain to
positive emotions so a crude example of
what I just described is somebody that
has fairly limited knowledge of words
that describe positive emotional states
so perhaps they recognize the word happy
they recognize the word ecstatic they
recognize the word joyful but they have
a fairly limited word set that pertains
to positive emotions whereas by
comparison this is always relative
within the same person right by
comparison the person knows four times
more words that pertain to a negative
emotional state okay in general those
people tend to be more depressive tend
to have higher levels of anxiety and so
forth as compared to somebody where the
reverse pattern is true where they have
knowledge of far more words that pertain
to positive emotional states as compared
to negative emotional states now on the
face of it that result probably seems
straightforward right people that have a
lot of words to describe happiness are
more happy people that have a lot of
words to describe sadness and negative
emotions are more sad but it didn't
necessarily have to be that way and it
turns out that it's not always that way
what do I mean by that well the
particular study that I've been
describing here this natural emotion
vocabularies as Windows on distress and
well-being is an important paper because
it explored not the words that people
have knowledge of but the word patterns
that people tend to use in their natural
speech either spoken or written and what
pen Baker and others showed is that
people that tend to use a lot of
negative words tend to have more
negative emotional states whereas people
that naturally tend to use words that
describe positive emotional states have
more positive emotions and this related
to both mental and and physical metrics
of negative emotions and positive
emotions so this is a significant result
because what it says is that our
knowledge of vocabulary words is while
interesting and perhaps important for
other things is not nearly as important
as which particular words we use on a
frequent basis and so whereas before I
said okay if you're going to embark on
this protocol of four writing sessions
15 to 30 minutes each that you should
not monitor your writing that you want
to sit down start writing and just don't
stop you don't want to pay attention to
grammar or spelling or anything else and
then after the fourth writing session
you don't look at what you've written
for at least a week but then a week or
more later you go back and you read what
you've written paying careful attention
to the number of words that you use that
reflect a negative emotional or affect
as it's sometimes called state in the
first versus the second versus the third
versus the fourth journal entry now this
might seem a little bit uh detailed and
reductionist for a protocol that we
would discuss on this podcast here we're
really talking about you doing your own
data analysis of self but if you think
about it a practice like this both can
be very quick and highly informative so
for instance you can go back and simply
Circle all the words that at first blush
to you appear to reflect a negative
State and put a square around all the
words that just by your read seem to
reflect a positive State and then
compare them across those four journal
entries and of course you can opt to not
do any of this but what people find that
is what was discovered in the research
literature is that on average the
patterns of language use from the 1 to
the 4th entury shift dramatically such
that by the 4th entury people even
though they're still writing about the
same negative experience are writing
about that experience in a very
different way not only are they
naturally using fewer negative words to
describe their recollection and
experience experience of that negative
event but the number of positive words
is also increasing now this is important
because when pen Baker and colleagues
gave the instruction to people to do
this protocol they encouraged them to
think about three things before they
ever start writing the first is of
course to write about facts about that
difficult experience I think that's sort
of obvious that when people are going to
recall a difficult experience they're
likely to write down facts about that
experience the second thing that they
want to remind them to include were
emotions that they felt at the time of
the experience as well as emotions that
they happen to feel now about that
experience and third that people include
writing about any and all links that
come to mind about the negative
experience and things that may be
happening today or plans for the future
people from the past present or future
really any link no matter how distant it
might seem or how random it might seem
to include that in the the writing okay
so just to repeat the three things that
they were instructed to include before
they ever set their pens to paper or
started typing out their negative
experience first facts about the hard
experience so whatever they can recall
that happened in that hard experience or
perhaps it was something that didn't
happen and that was why it was a hard
experience but facts related to that
hard experience facts of the hard
experience second that they include
writing about emotions felt at the time
of the experience as well as emotions
felt now while writing about that prior
experience and third to include any
writing about any links that spring to
mind about the negative experience and
anything that's happening now or perhaps
happened in the past or things that you
have plan for the future now that third
category of links between the experience
and other things may be direct and
obvious maybe these are real aha moments
where you go oh my goodness I realize
now that you know what's been happening
for the last 6 months is a direct mirror
of what happened in that earlier
traumatic or very stressful episode or
perhaps the links are more opaque maybe
the link is you know I don't know why
but I keep thinking about this one
experience that I had and I keep
thinking about this one person and I
don't know how they're linked that's
fine put those down on paper you could
even draw a diagram but I should mention
it is important that you try to the best
of your ability to write things out in
complete sentences again they don't have
to be perfect grammar or even pseudo
perfect grammar the spelling can be off
your handwriting can be a mess although
if your handwriting is truly a mess it
might be hard to read later by the way
folks my older sister always teases me
that my handwriting is frozen in the
third grade actually uh would like to
show her my journal entries my
handwriting was actually quite a bit
better than it is now uh which basically
speaks to uh some degree of cognitive
decline for me but in any case the point
is that this third category of
establishing links between the prior
negative experience and whatever else is
an important component of the writing
protocol so whatever it takes to include
those links they are worth including now
I want to reemphasize that even though I
pointed to the positive health benefits
of using more positive words in one's
writing or speech as opposed to negative
words which tend to be associated with
worse Health outcomes both in terms of
physical and mental health it is
important and it's Central to this
writing protocol if you're going to get
the positive consequences of it that
you're not monitoring the words that
you're using too closely you're not
trying to write this so someone else can
see it you're not trying to write the
Great American novel you're not writing
your eulogy you're not writing your
autobiography you're really writing this
for you I can't emphasize that enough
you're doing this writing protocol so
that you can work through something that
is stressful or traumatic that resides
in your nervous system and that is not
serving you well indeed next we're going
to talk about what happens when these
narratives of our prior negative
experiences are not worked through that
they have not been put either to speech
or to pen to paper or typed out and
perhaps more importantly we're going to
talk about the incredibly positive
benefits both at the level of neural
changes SOC called neuroplasticity which
is the literal rewiring of neural
connections as well as psychological
benefits reduced anxiety improved mood
improved sleep and improved immune
function that are the consequence of
doing this four bouts of 15 to 30 minute
writing protocol as we all know quality
nutrition influences of course our
physical health but also our mental
health and our cognitive functioning our
memory our ability to learn new things
and to focus and we know that one of the
most important features of highquality
nutrition is making sure that we get
enough vitamins and minerals from
highquality unprocessed or minimally
processed sources as well as enough
probiotics and prebiotics and fiber to
support basically all the cellular
functions in our body including the gut
microbiome now I like most everybody try
to get optimal nutrition from Whole
Foods ideally mostly from minimally
processed or nonprocessed Foods however
one of the challenges that I and so many
other people face is getting enough
servings of high quality fruits and
vegetables per day as well as fiber and
probiotics that often accompany those
fruits and vegetables that's why way
back in 2012 long before I ever had a
podcast I started drinking ag1 and so
I'm delighted that ag1 is sponsoring the
hubman Lab podcast the reason I started
taking ag1 and the reason I still drink
ag1 once or twice a day is that it
provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com huberman to claim a special
offer they're giving away five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
huberman to claim that special offer
okay so let's talk a little bit about
the positive mental and in particular
physical changes that occur in people
that do this writing exercise I should
mention that most of the studies and
again more than 200 quality
peer-reviewed studies of this protocol
have been carried out and are still
ongoing not just in pennebaker
laboratory but in many many other
Laboratories as well reveal that the
positive physical shifts that occur in
people that complete this for bouts of
writing in the way I described is both
significant and longlasting now of
course it is not the case that these
four episodes of writing can completely
cure major forms of depression or post-
trumatic stress disorder although they
have been shown to benefit that is to
reduce depressive symptoms and to reduce
the symptoms of post-traumatic stress
disorder considerably but they shouldn't
be considered complete Therapeutics for
those conditions however however they
have been shown to significantly improve
many other health metrics and I alluded
to some of these at the beginning of
today's episode there have for instance
been studies of this type of journaling
protocol for people that have been
suffering from chronic anxiety and
insomnia and indeed they experienced
significant
relief as well people who have suffered
from arthritis people who are going
through cancer treatment people who have
Lupus which is an autoimmune disorder
report significantly improved symptoms
not necessarily cured from those
conditions but significantly improved
symptoms as a consequence of doing this
writing protocol in addition and earlier
I mentioned this I realized but I'll
mention again people suffering from
fibromyalgia which is a chronic pain
condition that is or can be very
debilitating has shown significant
Improvement in symptomology that is
reduced chronic pain after they do this
four bouts of writing in the way that I
described and again the relief from pain
seems to be ongoing again not a total
cure of their symptoms I don't want to
uh provide false hope here or overblow
the um the positive impact of this
particular writing protocol but
nonetheless statistically significant
shifts that were pervasive over time in
addition people suffering from IBS or
irritable bowel syndrome have achieved
some significant degree of relief of
their symptoms relative to people who
also have irritable bowel syndrome but
who do not do the exact same protocol
that we're talking about today now of
course in all of these studies we're not
talking about people that simply do this
writing protocol as compared to people
that don't do the writing protocol
pennebaker and others of course are
excellent scientists and so they provide
adequate control conditions the control
conditions in most cases were to have
people also do 15 to 30 minutes of
writing but to do journaling in the more
conventional manner of autobiographical
report of what they've been up to lately
or what they plan to do in fact very
much like my journal entries from
college and uh in the subsequent to that
so it's important to understand that
what we're talking about today is a
journaling protocol which seems somewhat
conventional but the exact protocol is
highly unusual as we've been talking
about throughout today's episode and in
addition all of the data that we're
discussing in terms of positive mental
and physical effects are data that were
established relative that is are
statistically significant as compared to
a control group that also wrote for an
equivalent amount of time time tended to
write out an equivalent number of words
on average and yet we're writing about
something quite different than the
people that were in the so-called
experimental group so it's important to
keep in mind that we're not simply
talking about phenomenology here we're
talking about scientific studies where
very specific measurements of the
experimental group that is the group
that did this particular form of writing
about something very distressing or even
traumatic four times 15 to 30 minutes
per time relative to a control group
that did nearly the equ equivalent form
of mechanical processes of writing but
that the specific emotional content
related to that writing was the major
variable that differed in fact that is
one particular strength of the protocol
we're describing today that if you think
about it would be very hard to do in a
study say of physical exercise where you
have people perhaps you know run on a
treadmill getting their heart rate up to
85% of their maximum heart rate for 30
minutes 5 days a week you would expect
that that group compared to a group that
did nothing would experience
significantly greater shifts in positive
Health metrics like lowered blood
pressure certainly not during the
exercise bout during the exercise bout
you can bet that their blood pressure
and heart rate went way way up but that
of course afterwards they would adapt to
that exercise by having a resting heart
rate that was lower than any group that
did nothing or that walked on a
treadmill but it's actually very hard to
think about a control group that would
provide real equivalents of time spent
and effort spent but that would differ
only on one variable which would be
heart rate you could probably come up
with something but it'd be very
difficult to do whereas in the studies
that we're talking about during today's
episode essentially everything was the
same right people are still writing
they're still sitting they're still
doing it for the same amount of time
it's simply that the content of the
writing is different at the level of the
emotional tone of the subject that
they're writing about which I find both
exciting and personally quite motivating
to do the sort of protocol that I've
described today because it leads to such
dramatic shift in health across a huge
range of Dimensions both in people
suffering from certain conditions and
people who are not suffering from
certain conditions and then the question
becomes why what is actually happening
at a physiological level that can
explain all of these incredible
psychological and physical positive
shifts that occur okay so as with any
protocol that's shown in many many
studies again here are more than 200 100
peer-reviewed studies to have positive
effects on mental health or physical
health you can imagine that there's
going to be a constellation of positive
effects that occur that can explain say
the Improvement in autoimmune conditions
or the Improvement in anxiety that is a
reduction in anxiety or the Improvement
in sleep patterns it's not going to be
just one thing however there are some
general categories of physiological
changes that have been observed in
people that do the particular protocol
we're talking about today that I think
can explain a great number of the mental
and physical shifts that occur now one
of the more important studies in this
area that's been published and here
again this is a paper by jimes pen Baker
but I don't want to give the impression
that he's the only person or the only
laboratory that's looked at this
particular writing protocol many others
have as well and I'll provide links to
some of those in the show note captions
but this particular study I'm about to
describe explored how the disclosure of
traumas or the writing out of very
stressful
experiences can impact immune function
at the level of specific cell types of
our immune system that are challenged
in a way that mimics the sort of
challenge we would experience if we were
to be exposed to a bacteria or virus now
without getting into a detailed lecture
about immunology and by the way I did an
entire episode of The hubman Lab podcast
about immune function in the brain uh
some years ago and you can find that by
going to HUB lab.com just put immune
system into the search function it will
take you to that episode and to any
timestamps of other episodes where I
touch on the immune system or protocols
related to immune brain function in the
meantime this particular study is very
interesting and worth highlighting
because what they did was to essentially
have people do the exact same protocol
that we've been describing throughout
today's episode but they also included
blood draws from the subjects in those
experiments and they collected that
blood from subjects both before and
after the writing episodes in fact they
took the blood 15 weeks prior to the
study and again six weeks into the study
okay now keep in mind that people were
completing the writing exercise over the
course of at a maximum four weeks
but they were still monitoring these
subjects in terms of their psychological
and physical health after the final
writing exercise that was a key
component of essentially all of the
studies of this particular protocol
they'd assess people before they did the
writing assignment they assessed people
during the writing assignment and they
assess people often long after the
writing assignment was completed even
years after the writing assignment was
completed so in this particular
experiment they're drawing blood 15
weeks before and 6 weeks into the study
six weeks into the study is after all of
the writing that is the four bouts of
writing have been completed they also
divided subjects in this study into
people that were so-called high
disclosers so these are people that
revealed a lot about their particular
traumatic or stressful episode in their
writing and people that were low
disclosers they also included a control
group and the control group was
essentially as I described before it
consisted of people that also were doing
journaling for the equivalent amount of
time as people that were in the
experimental group but that we're not
writing about a traumatic or stressful
experience now the basic takeaway of the
study is as follows they take the blood
they are able to isolate from the blood
something called t-lymphocytes
t-lymphocytes are an essential component
of your immune system these are cells
that many people describe as white blood
cells they are manufactured in the bone
marrow which I still find amazing right
we think of bone is just these like you
know hard components of our body and our
skeleton that allow us to be upright and
to be rigid and to move about and you
know not be um you know jelly like but
indeed in the center of the bone is
marrow and the marrow itself is
performing an important physiological
role many roles in fact one of which is
to create these t-lymphocytes or white
blood cells they actually are born of
the bone marrow but then they mature in
a structure called the thymus the thymus
is an organ that sits essentially behind
your sternum and it's there that the
cells that originate from the bone
marrow
are matured into what are effectively
white blood cells which are essentially
cells that go out and combat infections
bacterial infections viral infections
even fungal infections now they combat
infection not alone but in collaboration
with other immune cell types that you
can learn about again in that episode
that I did about the immune system and
the nervous system if you choose to go
listen to it and even if you don't
here's what you need to know about this
study in this study what they found
is that when they took the blood from
these subjects isolated those T
lymphocytes and then challenged those
t-lymphocytes with something that mimics
an infection and they did that with
something called con canavalin a
concavalin a is what's considered aogen
it's something that activates
t-lymphocytes and it activates what are
called natural killer cells now that's a
lot of detail for sake of this episode
basically what the con canavalin a is
doing is it's mimicking an in section
but in this particular study this is all
being done on t-lymphocytes that have
been collected they're put into a dish
and then they're exposed to different
concentrations going from low to medium
to high of that con canavalin a
mimicking a lowgrade moderate or severe
infection and what they observed in this
study is remarkable I mean to me it this
just still blows my mind people that did
this four bouts of writing protocol
experienced greater degree of tlmy
activation from The concanavalin mitogen
Challenge which mimics infection then
did people who wrote about something
that wasn't stressful or traumatic now
that itself is pretty striking if you
think about it I mean we're talking
about a writing exercise that generates
an emotional state versus a writing
exercise that does not produce as
negative or intense an emotional state
and we're talking about a significant
effect on the immune system or the
mobilization of immune cells in response
to an immune
challenge in addition to that however
they observed that high disclosers that
is people that really poured themselves
into this writing protocol experienced a
greater degree of immune activation that
is a fighting off response to this
mitogen concanavalin a then did people
that were low disclosers so this really
speaks to the fact that the intensity
the emotional state during the writing
exercise is having a significant impact
on the immune system at the level of
something as basic and yet as powerful
as how much deployment of immune
response there is to an infection now
the field of so-called psychon
neuroimmunology has been around for more
than 30 years in fact if you don't apply
standard definitions to that field it's
been around for thousands of years but
really it's only in the last 10 years or
so that scientists and physicians at
least standard scientists and Physicians
have started to really adopt the
understanding and really apply to their
studies and their clinical practice this
firm idea that the body and mind are
linked in this way that emotions can
really shape our physical responses and
that physical responses also can shape
of course our mental responses now I'm
not trying to be disparaging at all of
traditional science or medicine it's
just that until recently these fields
have existed more or less as silos
people that studied bodily organs versus
people that studied the brain people
that studied emotions and psychology
versus people that studied the immune
system and there's been some crossover
but by and large it's been very siloed
now I mention this because if you look
into the history of why James pennebaker
and colleagues started exploring this
particular pattern of journaling it
actually relates to his own personal
experience and I don't want to spend too
much time on this but it's worth
mentioning that pener has actually
spoken about and written about in by the
way an excellent book that I've linked
to in the show note captions where he
talks about his experience in suffering
pretty severely from asthma as a child
and that that asthma was seasonal and
yet at some point later in his life
because he had certain relatives
visiting him in his new home
location that his asthma would come and
go as a consequence of interacting with
certain members of his family
independent of season and basically what
he deduced from his own personal
experience is that there must be some
link between our emotions either
negative or positive and our immune
system or other physical ailments or
thriving in the physical sense now he
certainly wasn't the first one to come
up with that hypothesis but indeed he
was one of the first to really start
exploring a protocol within the
laboratory an experimental protocol that
could really tap into high degrees of
emotionality in this case negative
emotions and the consequence of that on
physical health outcomes and this study
that I mentioned is but one one of those
examples and in that way he's truly a
Pioneer in thinking about quote unquote
psychon neuroimmunology but couching it
not in the direction that most people do
which is for instance there have been
lots of studies where people have said
okay in people that are chronically
stressed which includes of course
psychological stress what are the
effects on the nervous system the immune
system Etc and as you could imagine in
general people who were more stressed
over long long periods of time had worse
physical outcomes and people who were
less stressed had better physical
outcomes but the protocol that we're
talking about today is quite a bit
different so if you step back and think
about it's a little counterintuitive
what pennebaker essentially did was to
have
people deliberately induce a negative
experience and yet they're seeing
positive physical health outcomes or in
this case positive effects on immune
system function so that leads to the
question of what's really happening
during an after these four episodes of
writing and that's where things get
especially interesting as it relates to
the nervous system system and to
neuroplasticity or the nervous system's
ability to rewire itself in response to
experience so that's what we're going to
talk about next I'd like to take a quick
break and thank our sponsor insid
tracker insid tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test a
major problem with a lot of blood tests
out there however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
make it very easy because they have a
personalized platform that allows you to
see the levels of all those things
metabolic factors lipids hormones Etc
but it gives you specific directives
that you can follow that relate to
nutrition behavioral modification
supplements Etc that can help you bring
those numbers into the ranges that are
optimal for you if you'd like to try
inside tracker go to insid tracker.com
huberman for this week only meaning now
through November 26th insid tracker is
offering 50% off all bundles and 30% off
all other tests again that's
insidetracker
docomo okay so what's happening at a
mechanistic level that allows people who
do these four bouts of writing about
something traumatic or stressful to
achieve these longlasting positive
shifts in mental and physical health now
there could be any number of different
changes occurring at the level of the
mind or body but what we're talking
about here is trying to find the pivotal
one or sometimes referred to as the
Lynch pin mechanism that when one Taps
into that mechanism it Wicks out into
all these different systems of the brain
and body and provides all of these
different positive benefits now in
researching this episode I thought long
and hard about this and came up with a
short list of ideas and as is always the
case people have worked in this area on
this particular protocol and protocols
similar to it in the the field of
Psychology and Neuroscience have also
generated their own short list and those
short lists converge at the level of one
particular mechanism that is worth
describing and that one particular
mechanism is anchored around the concept
of neuroplasticity that is our nervous
systems ability to change in response to
experience and if you've heard me talk
about neuroplasticity before
neuroplasticity in childhood occurs
through rather passive experience of any
sorts of events in fact one of the
Hallmarks of childhood is that just the
mere exposure to an experience reshapes
the brain not necessarily permanently
but often in a way that is very
longlasting now that's a feature of
childhood because if you think about
what the nervous system is really
designed to do for us it's of course
what allows us to move our limbs it's
what allows us to have a heart rate that
goes in the background without us having
to think about it so-called autonomic
functions it's what keeps us breathing
without us having to think about it and
on and on but one of the main functions
of the nervous system is to be a
predictive machine to make good guesses
about what's to come next and one of the
ways to make really good guesses about
what's to come next is to take a certain
period of life that we call childhood
superimpose on that period of life that
childhood what we call a critical period
or sensitive period during which our
experiences create a sort of map within
us that allow us to predict okay well if
this person's in the room later well
then that's likely to happen or if those
people are in the room any number of
different things could happen but of one
particular category of experience as
opposed to another that's really what
your nervous system does it becomes a
prediction machine and it becomes a
prediction Machine by drawing strong
correlations between emotional states
your physical surroundings your
perception of who's there what's there
what happened just prior to something
and how it made you feel later so when
we talk about recounting a stressful or
traumatic event if you recall there were
three components to it it involved facts
about that experience so literally who
was there what happened as to the best
of our recollection if you recall the
second thing it's also about recounting
how that experience made you feel at the
time and how it makes you feel now and
then if you recall the third thing
that's critical to include it's about
any links or associations between what
happened and really anything at all so
if you think about it all three of those
things in that list are really about
tapping into your neural map or your
schema as it's sometimes called or your
internal representation both conscious
and unconscious of what happened during
that stressful or traumatic event now a
Hallmark feature of traumas as well as a
Hallmark feature of addictions as well
as a Hallmark feature of compulsive
behaviors or negative habitual behaviors
and negative habitual States like
chronic stress anxiety the sorts of
things that trigger insomnia the sorts
of states of body that trigger immune
compromise and give us autoimmune or
other types of immune system challenges
are that a certain component of our
nervous system and our brain in
particular are less engaged than they
normally would be in the healthy
condition now I want to be clear that in
any one of these conditions whether or
not it's irritable bowel syndrome or
it's fibromyalgia or it's chronic
anxiety or depression there are many
many different brain centers and
networks that is stations within the
nervous system of the brain and body
that are involved I really want to
emphasize this there's no one location
in the brain for instance for fear or
anxiety it's always a network phenomenon
the relative activation of different
brain centers at different times and so
on but with respect to thinking about
traumas and stressful experiences we
have to ask ourselves what is it about
the emotional states and all the mapping
the representation around those
emotional experiences that would somehow
impact our immune system like our thymus
of all things or our bone marrow or
conversely what would it be about a
stressful experience that would impact
our heart rate that would somehow then
also change our brain so the mechanism
that seems to be a sort of Smoking Gun
of sorts that is the mechanism that
really does seem to be at least one of
those Lynch pin mechanisms is that when
we experience very stressful or
traumatic experiences our prefrontal
cortex the neural real estate that's
just behind our forehead which has
several different subdivisions in fact
is reduced in its overall levels of
activity and other areas of the brain
that sometimes are referred to as the
limit LIC areas of the brain although if
we were to be more accurate than that
the modern Neuroscience really refers to
these as subcortical structures they
aren't necessarily lyic structures per
se although they can include components
of the lyic system so they can include
things like the hypothalamus so this
dense collection of neurons that resides
over the roof of your mouth that's
involved in things like aggression or
temperature regulation sleep wake cycles
and so on as well as structures that
perhaps you've heard more about such as
the amygdala which is involved in threat
detection but other structures as well
all of which are subcord cortical now
those subcortical structures can be
compared in a fairly General but still
accurate way to the prefrontal cortex
which is involved in contextual planning
involved in assessing outcomes if I do a
what will happen if I do B what will
happen the prefrontal cortex is also
associated with our
self-concept of our identity who we are
what we are about what we value what
motivates our decisions to do or to not
do things so I don't want to create any
false impressions that the prefrontal
cortex is somehow a more evolved
structure than the subcortical and lyic
structures but in some sense it is it's
involved in more quote unquote
sophisticated functions or at least
functions that involve us really
thinking and being able to place a
coherent Narrative of what happened in
the past what's happening now and what's
likely to happen in the future if
conditions a b or c happen to arise okay
so that's a very brief top level Contour
less in prefrontal cortical function and
comparing it a bit to some subcortical
and lyic structure functions now there
have been neuroimaging studies in
particular Studies by the liberman
laboratory at University of California
Los Angeles but neuroimaging studies in
other Laboratories as well that have
established that when people recount
very stressful or traumatic events the
prefrontal cortex level of activity is
reduced as compared to when people
recall less stressful or less traumatic
events
in addition to that those subcortical
structures ramp up their activity when
people recall traumatic events at least
at first okay this is very important
what I'm about to tell you is that the
repeated visiting of stressful and
traumatic events in a structured way or
even in a pseudo structured way as is
the case when people first start
journaling about that stressful or
traumatic event on day one when it tends
to be a pretty unstructured narrative
that's actually been shown in the
literature and then over the course of
that second and third and fourth writing
bout people not only shift the sort of
language that they use to describe their
feelings and that event as we talked
about earlier but the degree to which
there's a more coherent narrative placed
on the structure of that writing
increases with each subsequent bout of
writing and this is very important
because what we're really talking about
here is people going deeper into their
recollection of the experience not
remaining at such a superficial level
and two things are happening even though
they're going deeper into this very
distressing event they're perhaps even
experiencing heightened levels of
distress right if you recall back to
earlier in the episode when I talked
about people who tend to be on the low
disclosure end of things they're not
very rbos they don't tend to use a lot
of emotional words and early on they're
not sharing too much about this
experience and over time it increases
whereas the other group decreased the
level of emotionality with each
subsequent writing bout but in each case
the coherence of the narrative that is
the degree to which the narrative takes
on a story-like structure increases from
the first to the fourth writing bout and
this is very important because what
we're really talking about here is
increasing the amount of
[Music]
truthtellah
in your mind what were the facts what
happened what didn't happen perhaps is
relevant too but what happened second
how did it make you feel that's
something that you are uniquely
qualified to answer factually because
only you can really know how you feel
sometimes it takes some effort to think
into how you feel to really get a clear
sense of how you felt and how you feel
but only you can report that factually
no one can dispute that those are your
feelings and that's part of what you're
writing about and then of course there's
the third component of what are the
connections between different
experiences that are coming to mind and
there again that is your unique factual
report of what's going on inside your
head around that event okay so what
we're talking about here is an exercise
in writing that yes is distressing but
that we know Based on neuroimaging data
overtime is increasing the Baseline
levels of activity in certain key areas
of the prefrontal cortex and that we
know is associated with improvements in
the symptomology around trauma and other
stressful events now it's extremely
important to highlight this
truth-telling component and the fact
that your truth about these experiences
is indeed your truth and it's such a key
component of the writing exercise so
what we're looking at here is a
situation where the event or events that
happened actually happen there's no
changing that but your narrative about
those events is vitally important in
terms of how you experience either Ono
going distress from or relief from those
events and in sort of a counterintuitive
way reporting those events in a way that
initially is very stressful or that can
be stressful in any number of those
different four writing bouts over time
provides relief from that stress so why
do I say counterintuitive well you could
say okay well then does distress itself
cause changes in the prefrontal cortex
that are positive No in fact the
opposite is true we know that being
under I conditions of duress or stress
or trauma reduces activity in the
prefrontal cortex and here we're saying
recalling that trauma and stress in ways
that are highly emotional and negative
is actually increasing ongoing activity
in the prefrontal cortex and indeed yes
that is the case so how could that be
during development neuroplasticity is a
passive process whatever we are exposed
to changes our brain in a way that
allows us to more reliably predict the
future right that's one of the key
functions of the brain but as an adult
meaning from age 25 onward and really
that's not a strict cut off could be
late teens maybe 19 all the way up to
say age 120 which we think is perhaps
the maximum lifespan that humans could
possibly reach we don't know most people
don't reach 120 but let's say from 19
all the way up to 120 we know that
neuroplasticity is created when the
nervous system goes into states that are
atypical as compared to our normal
waking States and one of the key
triggers for neuroplasticity is when we
have high levels of the so-called
catacol amines dopamine epinephrine
Endor norepinephrine in our brain and
body that creates a state change that we
call autonomic nervous system shift
where we have elevated heart rate more
distress High degrees of emotionality it
is highly uncomfortable often and yet
that signals to the neural tissue hey
something's happening here and we need
to rewire we need to change and the
actual rewiring occurs during deep sleep
sleep and states such as non-sleep deep
rest or anytime we're in a deep
relaxation State some of you have heard
me talk about neuroplasticity before but
the key elements to remember for today's
discussion is that these states of
heightened levels of emotionality are
the trigger for neuroplasticity and that
the actual rewiring of neural
connections happens in sleep and states
such as non-sleep deep breast so if we
were to be completely logical we would
sit back at this point and say okay
here's a protocol in which we
deliberately make ourselves stressed out
again about a very stressful or
traumatic event and yet even though that
stressful or traumatic event at first
created problems for our mental and
physical health by revisiting it and
triggering that stressful experience
again four times in a lot of detail
somehow it's giving me relief from that
experience it's creating positive mental
and physical shifts I mean how could
that be how could it be that the
negative experience on the one hand
creates problems and then on the other
hand recreating that negative experience
relieves those very same problems
there's something completely illogical
about that framework right well here's
where things get really interesting
there have been two separate collections
of work in the Psychology and
Neuroscience literature in the last 10
years which have focused mainly on two
concepts the first concept is that
extremely stressful and traumatic
experiences because they induce a
relative reduction in the activity in
the prefrontal cortex
divorce our mind from creating a
coherent structural narrative about what
happened during those particular
episodes and in doing so create a sort
of confusion about responsibility now
there's a whole discussion to be had
about this and we will have that
discussion in a future episode of the
podcast about how trauma is actually
mapped within the brain and body there
are a lot of theories about this right
sometimes we hear that it's all mapped
within the body sometimes we hear it's
all mapped within the brain turns out as
is almost always the case it's both but
there does seem to be both
neuroscience-based and psychology both
clinical and research psychology based
evidence for the idea that when people
experience very stressful and traumatic
events that the representation of those
events is somewhat fractured in the
sense that people by not talking about
them by not creating a coherent
narrative around them start to form
false correlations between the kind of
stress that they create in our body and
mind when we think about them and a
confusion about what happened a
confusion about why we feel terrible
when maybe we weren't the perpetrator or
create a sort of lack of coherence
between our bodily State and what we're
thinking especially because we're not
the perpetrator right here we're talking
about traumas and stressful things that
happened to us maybe we were
participants in that by virtue of our
circumstances but when we talk about
traumas what we're really talking about
are things that we would have never
elected to do otherwise okay so I don't
want to be too abstract about this but
again within the neuroscience and
psychology understanding of trauma and
stress it seems that there's a lack of
coherence about the narrative there's
also a mismatch between the bodily State
and thoughts about that experience and
there seems to be a confusion about who
or what was responsible for inducing
that negative state in a way that in
some sense causes people to set aside
that narrative and try and push it away
and not think about it because it is
confusing it can often even be
discombobulating for those that have
suffered from very stressful events and
Trauma I think some of this will
resonate with you now a separate
literature that's largely nested just
within the Neuroscience Community
although it's starting to Wick out into
the psychology Community as well is the
idea that when people tell the truth and
in particular when people tell the truth
with a very coherent structured
narrative the levels of activity in the
prefrontal cortex increase but not just
temporarily that is that there's
neuroplasticity of these prefrontal
cortical structures which are both
involved in generating coherent
narratives but are also involved in this
is super important that are also
involved in regulating the activity of
those subcortical structures like the
hypothalamus and lyic structures in
other words that when we can increase
our understanding of an event when we
can understand why certain emotions
arose what our role in it really was
what others roles in that particular
event were well then by incre ining the
activity of the prefrontal cortex it's
better both in that moment and going
forward to regulate the activity of
these other subcortical structures and I
think one of the more impressive
experiments within that whole field of
linking prefrontal activity to
truth-telling is an experiment that was
published a few years ago in the
proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences entitled increasing honesty in
humans with non-invasive brain
stimulation now this is a very
artificial scenario where people come
into the laboratory and they have people
do what is essenti a die rolling game
they roll dice okay so they're rolling
Dice and then after they roll the dice
only they can see the score that they
get with those Dice and then a number is
presented on a screen and they have to
report whether or not the die roll that
they did matches or does not match the
number that's presented on the screen
and if it does match then they get a
monetary award and the monetary award is
not huge but it's not insignificant
either for each die roll where they
match the number that's presented on the
screen they get the equivalent of and
because this experiment was done in
Switzerland nine Swiss Franks which at
the time of the study corresponded
roughly to $9 and today corresponds to
roughly
$10 so they do this repeatedly and so in
some sense the subjects in these
experiments are in a place to make not
an enormous amount of money but again
not an insignificant amount either now
here's the key component of the study
the statistics of the dice that they
roll and the statistics of die rolling
and the numbers that they are
presented make sure that there can only
be a correct match on average 50% of the
time okay and in this experiment the
subjects are asked to report entirely on
the honor System what they got when they
rolled the dice and what one finds in
this study and other studies that have
been done subsequent to it is that when
you take everyday people so you take men
and women you take a broad age range
you're not selecting for sociopaths
you're not selecting for people in one
given profession or another pick your
favorite profession if you were to
assume any one given profession has less
honest people than others they collect
people from all sorts of walks of life
and people report getting the same
number that is presented to them that is
a match about 68% of the time which
means they are not Faithfully reporting
what happened now Nur Imaging studies
show that when people lie certain areas
of the frontal cortex increase in their
activity although the major effect when
one looks neurally is a reduction in the
prefrontal cortex and in particular
subcompartments of the prefrontal cortex
that we'll talk about in a moment and
this particular study entitled
increasing honesty in humans with
non-invasive brain
stimulation as the name suggests used
non-invasive brain stimulation so this
is transcranial magnetic stimulation
which is a really nice and convenient
tool because you don't have to drill
down through the skull you can simply
put this tool it's a little coil you put
it over a particular part of the brain
but on the outside of the skull indeed
on the outside of the hair and you can
either inhibit or stimulate particular
brain areas using this transcranial
stimulation I've actually had this done
not in this particular experiment but I
had it done when I was a graduate
student some years ago and it was placed
over my motor cortex and I was
instructed to tap my fingers in a
particular sequence and then they
inhibit neur activity in a particular
brain area and I was unable to tap in
that same sequence and they could even
shut down my ability to tap it was
terrifying frankly although I don't want
to discourage anyone from participating
in any of these experiments should you
choose and yes of course your motor
abilities come back immediately
afterwards that's why they can run these
experiments now in this experiment what
they did is they stimulated or inhibited
neural activity in particular areas of
the prefrontal cortex and what they
discovered was I think and many others
by the way also agree a remarkable
result
which is that when they stimulated over
a particular region of the prefrontal
cortex people's honest report of what
happened when they rolled the die
relative to the number they were
presented increased okay so they went
from reporting that they had matched the
number on the screen and therefore won
money 68% of the time that number was
reduced down to what down to 50% of the
time in other words this stimulation of
the prefrontal cortex
took dishonest people even though they
were should we say mildly dishonest or
dishonest only in certain conditions
there were getting into judgment calls
and I don't want to do that and made
them truly honest they Faithfully
represented reality when a particular
area of the prefrontal cortex and that
area by the way is the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex was activated they
became truly honest they Faithfully
represented what happened in the diary
rolling game now the conditions in this
experiment are Far and Away different
from the journaling protocol that we've
talked about up until now however there
have been subsequent studies that have
shown that indeed when people tell the
truth to the best of their abilities
they are absolutely trying to Faithfully
report what happened in a given
experience of theirs activity in the
prefrontal cortex goes up and it
persists afterwards there is indeed
neuroplasticity of the prefrontal cortex
so the hypothesis that seems to be the
most likely and indeed has the greatest
weight of evidence for it is that when
people accurately and truthfully report
an experience even if that experience is
a stressful and traumatic one the
repeated activation of the prefrontal
cortex that occurs during that
truthtellah a sort of runaway positive
effect in the sense that it creates a
more coherent framework and
understanding of the stressful thing
that happened right so all that
discombobulation and that lack of
coherent story that then leads to lack
of coherence in terms of one's autonomic
function so underlying stress and
confusion about who's responsible that
does seem to be resolved or at least
partially resolved and the prefrontal
cortex of course doesn't Harbor one area
just for faithful accurate reporting of
traumas and stressful events that very
same area that dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex is responsible for faithful
reporting of all sorts of other things
and there are now more and more studies
showing that
truthtellah are in agreement that when
one sees all these positive shifts in
say immune system function like how
could it be that these cells produced by
the bone marrow and the thymus are
somehow better able to deal with an
infection when one has recounted a
traumatic or stressful event right first
of all it's counterintuitive second of
all why would that be I mean how are the
body and brain linked in that way well
they're linked through this thing that
we call the nervous system and the key
component of the nervous system in this
context is that when the prefrontal
cortex can organize its understanding of
why our autonomic nervous system was so
active well then the autonomic nervous
system it seems becomes less likely to
be active when it's not supposed to okay
that could at least partially explain
the reductions in anxiety the
improvements in sleep the reductions in
insomnia and because the nervous system
and the immune system are in direct
communication this often isn't discussed
but not only does the immune system
impact the brain but the brain has
Networks literally neural circuits that
inate structures like the spleen like
the phalus that can communicate with the
bone marrow right this isn't science
fiction this is really the case in fact
there was an article that just came out
in the journal Nature this month and
I'll provide a link to in the show note
captions which is finally starting to
acknowledge that yes while these fields
of immunology and brain science and
psychology have existed as disperate
silos up until now it's oh so clear that
the nervous system is the connection
between all these different components
of brain and body and so while it might
seem counterintuitive that a writing
protocol of the sort that we've been
talking about today could positively
impact the immune system or that a
writing protocol of the sort that we
were talking about today could
positively impact things like
Fibromyalgia symptoms well it makes
perfect sense really when we start to
think about the prefrontal cortex as
this highly flexible seat of our
cognition about our self-representation
our ideas about who we are and about
when certain elements within our brain
and body ought to be activated and when
they ought not to be activated because
so much of the negative symptomology of
stressful events and traumas is about
the kind of disarray and discombobulated
activation of wakefulness in the middle
of sleep right getting woken up in the
middle of the night and not being able
to go back to sleep or elevated heart
rate panic attacks anxiety and on and on
I talked about some of this in the hubin
lab podcast episode that I did about
stress and how to master stress with
particular protocol olss it also came up
in the discussion with Dr Paul kti in
the episode about trauma and the series
on mental health so what we're pulling
together here is a mechanistic
understanding of why something like
writing for 15 to 30 minutes about a
stressful or traumatic episode would or
even could induce all these positive
shifts in mental and physical health and
while we don't have a complete
understanding about the underlying
mechanisms the activation and the
neuroplasticity of the prefrontal cortex
seems to be one of the most logical and
the most likely that sits at the center
of at least the top list of the most
important mechanisms I want to be clear
that yes indeed I'm saying that when you
write about your truth about the facts
the events of an experience and your
emotions as they relate to that
experience and the connections that you
draw between any number of different
things around that experience that the
truth telling is the stimulus and that
the emotion that accompanies that
truth-telling is what allows for
neuroplasticity to occur and that indeed
truthtreatments
course and in fact the data on the sort
of journaling that we talked about today
indicate that people's progression
through talk therapy drug therapies etc
for depression and PTSD is accelerated
and significantly so when they do this
type of journaling so the sort of
journaling we're talking about today and
other therapies are not mutually
exclusive and yet the journaling
protocol that pen Baker and colleagues
came up with I think is spectacular
because it has a number of important
features and some of those are perhaps
obvious to you already first of all it's
completely Z zero cost I mean it costs a
bit of time but not even that much time
it has an emotional cost we should
acknowledge that it's intense right and
the more intense it seems the more
effective and third it's something that
really can be done either in the course
of four days or across an entire month
so it has some degree of flexibility to
it I would even say a great degree of
flexibility to it and last but certainly
not least it's been shown over and over
again I mean more than 200 peer-reviewed
studies not just from pener but from
others as well to have Myriad positive
effects on the body and the mind in ways
that are not just short-term but that
are pervasive not just over months but
indeed over years so I don't know about
you but when I first learned about this
literature I was well initially a little
bit skeptical because that's just my
nature I'm like wait how could
journaling have such a huge impact I
mean I've been journaling for years I
know other people that journal on a
regular basis and I've never heard of
this particular impact and I certainly
haven't heard heard or seen the data but
when I started looking at the data I
thought oh my goodness like how come I
haven't heard about this and I I don't
really have an answer for that although
I will say that penne Baker and others I
think were very early in their merging
of Mind and Body States although the
initial studies weren't really focused
on mind and body all the emphasis on
immune system and brain and Neuroscience
that actually came later so I think one
of the reasons we haven't heard about
this particular form of journaling is
that frankly it's nested within the
academic literature I haven't heard much
about it being incorporated into
clinical practices although I am sure it
is incorporated into clinical practices
and frankly whatever the reason I'm just
grateful to my colleague Dr David
Spiegel who again is our associate chair
of Psychiatry at Stanford he's a medical
doctor of incredibly highly esteemed
worldwide for his work on
neuroplasticity and helping people with
Stress and Anxiety and all sorts of
other challenges for informing me about
it so much so that I decided that next
month I'm going to do one bout of
writing for each week within that month
I've opted to not do the four
consecutive days of writing to me just
personally that seems a bit too intense
it's not the time commitment it's the
emotional commitment of placing myself
into close proximity of some really
challenging stressful maybe even
traumatic memories day after day after
day for 4 days personally I don't want
to do that other people might opt to do
that in um you know tighter succession
and do the the four days in a row what
the literature tells us again is that it
doesn't really matter um as long as you
do the four bouts of writing sometime
within a month period doesn't matter if
they all are back-to-back days or you
spread them out by a week or so just to
recap the other components of the
protocol you're going to write about the
same event for all four writing episodes
those writing episodes can be anywhere
from 15 to 30 minutes but not less
throughout each writing episode you're
going to continuously write right unless
you need to stop to catch your breath or
wipe your eyes dry of Tears you're going
to keep writing it is not necessary to
pay attention to grammar or spelling but
some degree of coherence maybe not
perfect complete sentences but some
degree of coherence is probably useful
especially if you decide to go back and
analyze what you wrote later which again
is an option you don't have to do that
but if you do want to do that you're
going to go back and circle the negative
words that is the words that you
perceive to be negative and you're going
to square the words that are positive
and if you like you can also reread them
and see whether or not as was observed
in the studies that we described there
was an increase in the amount of
coherence about the topic or the event
that you wrote about keep in mind that
for each of the four boutots of writing
you want to include both facts about the
events facts about how you felt and or
feel about those events now and third
any associations
whatsoever that happen to come to mind
about those events emotional states
people in your life anything past
present or future that third category of
things to include is really open to you
for anything you want to include the
only requirement for it to be included
is that it's true for you keep in mind
also that this writing protocol is for
you it is not necessarily to be shared
now there isn't a rule that says that
you cannot share it with anybody
although I do want to introduce the
important caveat that if you are going
to share it with someone that person
should be a dedicated Health Care
ideally mental health care professional
because there are data that suggest that
when we write about traumatic and
stressful events while it can be very
beneficial for us it can actually be
traumatic or challenging for people that
we read it to now there's huge variation
around that statement certainly many of
you probably know friends or family
members or other trusted ones that you
can talk to that would be able to hear
about your stressful or traumatic
experience and not be traumatized by it
however it does seem that the listener
can experience trauma and negative
symptoms such as challenges sleeping
distress Etc by hearing about very
stressful events that have occurred to
others okay this is thirdhand trauma or
observational trauma sometimes called so
if we were to adhere to the protocol as
it was used in the various studies that
form the basis for what we're talking
about today we would say that you are
writing about something that is for your
eyes only in fact you are welcome to
tear up or delete the document
afterwards and certainly you would want
to store it in a safe place so that it's
not going to fall into hands of somebody
that you wouldn't want seeing the
contents of that writing the other thing
to keep in mind is that while it's been
demonstrated over and over again that
over time these bouts of writing lead to
improvements in mental and physical
health as we talked about earlier it is
very normal and in fact quite likely
that one will feel pretty activated in
the negative sense that one will feel
somewhat low depressed angry sad
immediately after finishing one of these
bouts of writing especially if you fall
into the high expressor category so it's
important that as we mentioned earlier
that you have a buffer of time after
which you complete the writing before
moving into your other day's events I
also just personally wouldn't recommend
that you do this writing exercise just
prior to trying to go to sleep at night
if the experience is especially
stressful or traumatic and by definition
the writing exercise focuses on
stressful and traumatic events so keep
that in mind as well and then as a final
point but certainly a significant one is
to keep in mind that if this writing
protocol is creating in you significant
enough amounts of stress either
psychological or physical that you
simply don't want to do it or that it's
impeding other areas of life by all
means just stop okay there was very
little if any data within the papers
that I read that indicated that people
had to be removed from the study for
this reason but keep keep in mind that
we're talking about purposefully delving
into stressful or traumatic experiences
and writing about them in some detail so
it stands to reason that some people
might not be able to tolerate that and I
want to strongly request that before
anyone embark on this writing protocol
that you ask yourself whether or not you
are indeed prepared to deal with the
emotional state that might accompany
faithful accurate recollection of what
happened what you felt and any links or
experiences a full four four times
across the protocol I also see no reason
why you couldn't do this protocol for
something that wasn't the most stressful
or traumatic event in your life but
rather take your first pass at this
protocol with something that was very
stressful maybe even traumatic but
perhaps not the most traumatic event as
a way of sampling whether or not it's
for you in fact I plan to do that in
reviewing the literature and preparing
for today's episode I wrote down two
things possibly three that I would want
to write about and then I ra ated them
one through three one being the most
stressful perhaps even traumatic the
other being less stressful and the third
the least stressful of the three and
decided to go with writing about the
second in that list that is the
moderately stressful AK traumatic event
um as a way to First weade into this
protocol but I will adhere to the
protocol I'm going to write about that
same thing four times as opposed to
switching from one event to the next
Midway through the protocol so I am
going to adhere to the protocol I'll
certainly be happy to get back to you
and let you know how it goes I invite
you if you like to embrace this protocol
to try it we've provided links to the
literature that supports this protocol
again it's very rare perhaps the first
time that I've ever done an entire
podcast episode about a single protocol
or to formulate an entire podcast around
a protocol but frankly I don't look at
this protocol from pennebaker and
colleagues as just a protocol I look at
it as an entire body of literature that
includes a center of massive data that
all seem to point in the same direction
which is that writing about something
very stressful or traumatic for 15 to 30
minutes four times either on consecutive
days or separated out by a week between
each of those four writing sessions can
produce long lasting positive effects on
mental and physical health and to me
that's a protocol that is simply too
valuable to overlook and simply too
valuable to not share with you if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc costway
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a f star review
please check out the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or topics or
guests that you'd like me to consider
for the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments not on
today's episode but on many previous
episodes of The hubin Lab podcast we
discussed supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for every everybody
many people derived tendous benefit from
them for things like improving sleep for
hormone support and for improving Focus
to learn more about the supplements
discussed on the hubman Lab podcast you
can go to live momentus spelled o so
it's Liv mous.com huberman if you're not
already following me on social media I'm
hubman lab on all social media platforms
so that's Instagram Twitter now called X
LinkedIn Facebook and threads and on all
of those platforms I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlap with the contents of the hubman
podcast but much of which are distinct
from the contents of the hubman Lab
podcast so again it's hubman lab on all
social media platforms if you haven't
already subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a monthly newsletter that's
completely zero cost that includes
podcast summaries as well as toolkits
toolkits are brief PDFs that describe
protocols for things like
neuroplasticity for improving your sleep
for dopamine regulation for exercise
flexibility and on and on again all
completely zero cost to sign up for the
neural network newsletter you simply go
to huberman lab.com go to the menu tab
scroll down to newsletter and put your
email there you'll receive an email and
if you approve you'll start receiving
the monthly newsletter again it's
completely zero cost and I want to point
out that we do not share your email with
anybody thank you for joining for
today's episode where we discussed a
journaling protocol that has been
demonstrated in the scientific
literature to significantly improve
mental and physical health and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in
[Music]
science